t you do
こんにちは
うっはぁんっ
面白かったらスタンディングオベーションしてくださいね
最初は強いと申します今日はですね
僕がやっておりますドラゴン桜プロジェクトの話をしたいと思いますか
ドラゴン桜吸ってる人を
皆さんご存知でございますね落ちこぼれの高校生が東大を目指して勉強頑張って人生を
変えるという話でございましたが
僕たちのチームはですねこのドラゴン桜を世界中で行っております
なぜこんなことを始めたのかと申しますと
こちらでございますね
私の元彼女でございます
彼女にですねある日振られたことからすべて始めません
さぁ今日はちゃんとお付き合いくださいね笑ってやってくださいね
この子がですね別れ際に去っていくときにこんなことを申しました
女性にぜひ読み上げていただきたいんですがちょっといいですか読み上げていただいて
あなたがいつか雑誌木てる日が来たら
買うわ
ありございますそんなこんなことありがとうございます
そうでございますねー
こんなことを言ってされた日にはもう男子としてはね
ね読み返してやると見てろよということでございまして
こんなときにで行った落ち込みますよねやっぱりね
早になってます
この本読んだことは一つあるいますかねこれグラミン銀行をしてますという本でござい
まして
秋田大学の坪井先生が書いていた品でございます
これを読んですごい感動いたしまして
もう出演など何もやる事もなかったのですね
ちょっととりあえず夜行バスで飽きてあげると
いうことでございましてこの著者に会いに行ってございます
そしたら坪井先生驚いてましたね
実際はこんな形でございます
左ですよ
2ヴォイセズ彼女のメッセージはシンプルでございまして
そんなに気になるんだったらバングラディッシュに行って来いということでございまし
てですね
私
早稲田の友人2人釣れましてバングラデシュに行ってまいりました
心でございますねバングラディッシュ
こんな組でございましてとにかく人口が多いと
僕が貰った仕事はですねさっきのグラミン銀行どもをいただきましてなんでもいいから
下働きさせてくれということを言いました
そしてこのバーガーで篠村に行けば行くほどですねとにかく先生の数が足りないぞと
いうことでございまして
なんと皆さんこのバーガーで1種4万人先生が足りないということでございます
42の興味不足どうやって皆さんたら解決しますか
4万人でございますよ
その時ですね僕があるシーンを思い出しました
高校時代の私の成績でございます
100点もあるんですよ
どうやって3点取るんだ
教えましょうみてくださいん
全部ゼロって買えません
そしてたら奇跡的に2ターってやつか
じゃないですよ2点ばっか撮ってる場合じゃないですよ3点もところですん
いやいや僕だってやれるときあるんですよ見てるんだからがんばって白くてたですね
えっ
っていう落ちこぼれ高校生だったんでございますがやっぱりですねぼく早稲田大学
ダイスでございまして
早稲田に何とか行きたいともう行くところがここしかないということでございましです
ねこの緑の看板の予備校行ってここをとても不思議な予備校でございまして
全部 dvd でやんですよねー
しかもこんな変な先生たちが出てきました
この人たちの授業ですね dv で受けまくったらですねなんと1年間で併殺28から
はせた指も受かっちゃったんですね
ありがとうございますありがとうございます
今なぜママナースしたいわけじゃないんですけどもこのことですよここで思い出し
ちゃったもんなんですね
このモデルパクったらいいじゃないかと思った上でございます
このアイディアをですね僕が当時インターンしてましたグラミン銀行の総裁の浜と優先
しましたら気のせいせおっしゃったどぅ1個へ前へ前へ前へということでございました
あの尊敬するユーザー数が前へ前へと言っているということですね
これはやるしかないなと大学を休学してやるぞということを決めました
あとからこのゆる先生誰にでも前へ前へといったことが分かったんですが
まあそれが置いといてですね
このバッジですねバングラディッシュの流れの街だと思いますこれ
この看板垂れ幕全部バングラの宿のテーマ区なんですよ
塾予備校
アジアの債権国のバングラデシュにこんなにチェックとか予備校がありまして
塾予備校ある所には名物教師あり
バングラディッシュの
英語といえばこの男9-3さん
ないよ
バングラデシュ国こと言えば狩りハーブ
調べ役場いう声が聞けますよね社会といえばもう2回もんでしょうぞ
このせいぜいたちを口説きを起こしましてビデオに撮ってそれを dvd に焼いて船
で持っていくという
非常にシンプルなのでで e education 始まりました
この二年良く沈むんでございますねー
船で3時からいきますとこんな
超田舎につきましてですねこの田舎でプロジェクトを開始いたしました
こんな感じですね
始め女の子6人7年から始まりましていっ
せったんのが集まってきたということですね
目指すはバングラデシュの灯台ダッカ大学と言われますここに行ってみんなで人生
変えようぜということを言っていたら
これはまるでバングラデシュのドラゴン桜じゃないかということで
朝日新聞がバングラデシュ版ドラゴン桜始まると報じてからですね
僕たちのプロジェクトバングラ版ドラゴン桜と呼ばれるなりました
これパートナーのマフィン君でございます彼が今現地でですねリーダーシップを持って
やっていると
初めはこんな感じに楽しそうにやってるんですけどもいろんな問題が起こりましてです
ね
例えば金どうすんだろでございます彼
だいたいこれ1年間約200万円かかるんですね
もうお金ないのはお金が入ってたらなんと皆さんそんなときに限って
リボルバー強盗に襲われるという事件がありましてですね
でもこれ残金はなんと後4万円というございます
あと1か月できる16万円稼がないといけないんですけど
どうします
奪え解説書ぐらいですから
倍返し的なからですよね
皆さんどうします
稼ぐ
どうやって稼ぎます
経由してもらうとかですね僕たち考えついたの当時3つありましたね
親に行かれるご金額せいろ
学生ローンてね僕も入ってた早稲田大がたくさんあるんですよね
そしてですね最後に救世主が現れた
この3工場使ったことがあるちゃいますからこれ
頃5分でしょうということでございません
この頃後の板野先生の事務所に行きましたのですね板野先生が
受賞わかったと言ってオフィスの多くに入ってですね作れてゴソゴソやってると思っ
たらなんか風と思ってドシンとおいてくる
代価をあげたらなんという基地が80枚
途中6万円はクリフ机を雪像
なぁーん
出世払い有形無形とワースト
コーヒー他の先生
親鸞は突破したと思ったら皆さん
なんと体でんですよバングラデシュのムラー
こんなんじゃパソコンの授業できないですよね
どうします
ろうそくで
ろうそくもなかったら
朝になるのはぜ
かと思えば
あと思えば
どうします
電気ないんですけど
タブレットですタブレット
こちらでございますね
made in china のジェネレーター25000円でございます
これを購入してディーゼルを入れたらすごい電力出すんですよね
そしたらですねこのでレイターうるさくて勉強できないということになりました
結局 ups ってあの例の蓄電池使ってやったと
ハザマと皆さん稲妻スコールが降ったら大変ですよ
通学路がこんな買っちゃうよね
誰もこれないと
船は沈むしっ
米は笑い事じゃないんですよ
なぜこの船が沈むのかということです
400人の底に800に乗るからなんですね
これは笑えないですね800に乗った船が沈んだ誰も助かりませんからね
はたまた暴動が起きたら大変だと言う
私どうしてもこの暴動の日はですね外国人は皆外に出ちゃいけないんですよ
ただどうしてもこの日空港に行ってその飛行機を乗っていますあのだいあの東京にから
なきゃいけなかったですね
ただ皆さん外はこんなんですよ非常に激しい暴動活動をしている
とにかく4発思います
でも飛行機まであと三時間しかない
どうやってこの暴動状況を抜け出します
恥じる
演奏する返送するありそうですね
各部長らう
どうですか
やっぱり橋やっぱりさせるなるほど増
最後の手段はこれしかないんですよさ女子4
これじゃないですねこのすればバスもやってますね
この次のページでございましたこちらです茶
厩舎でございます答えは99社を買収するということでございましてその買収価額は
なんと4500円ということでございましてですね
空港までわずか30分で行けるとさすがに先ほどの暴徒たちもこの救急車が襲わないと
いうことでございました
こんな病気にもかかりましたね丁子麩と
大変だったぞ半年から皆さん無事にバングラで新事業を届けた結果
我らが高校生30人ダッカ大学の受験に向かっていきました
受験はこんな感じの風景でございます日本と似てますよね
彼が一体どうなったのかと申しますと
30人を受けてですねなんと18人も受かっちゃったんですよ
大学
ありがとうございます
ございます
米しかもこの真ん中のヘラルくんがですね拳をこうやっておりますけども
米の投打のだから輸入ガチャこれはすごい
まるでハブ茶村雨奇跡じゃないかということで現地の新聞にも取り上げらればいろいろ
いろいろですね
騒ぎになってこの8人
現在の生徒数は皆さんこんなになってますよ
みてください正品も独裁者からお湯が出ません
こんな本にもなっています舞え舞え舞えぜひ協約たよね
こんないろんなメディアでました news zero nhk おはよう日本と
色んなやりまし
早瀬ますじゃあ白砂を置いといてですねこんな話ありましたねぇ
これどうやったと思いますこれ
あなたはどうなったんだぞ
風虫
いいオチまでついたということでございました
まええじゃないかと魔兵はこんな偉くなった日ということでございます
僕たちはですねバングラデシュで行った後にこんな目標かかりまして
五大陸でやるぞということでございまして土田エレクドラゴン桜ということを
2年前からチャレンジしてですね現在10カ国
仲間20人でチャレンジをしている最中でございまして今日も仲間募集しておりますの
でこの後
ぜひ僕にお声掛けください
そして私が今個人的に力を入れている国がありまして
この仲間ですね進撃の巨人版ドラゴン桜というすごいな場合もあるんですねこれはどこ
でやってるかというとパレ下の画像でございましてですね
ガザのこの壁の中に最高の授業を送るということで釣ったここはですね
残念ながら時間がないということで
知りたい人はこちらの方用デザインですねムスカありますので最後の授業世界なんだ
届けなんでございます
そして現在最も大事なのはここでございます
ブラックホークダウン満たしています a がー
いらっしゃいますね世界で一番危険な国ソマリアで現在活動中ということでございます
変ですここ
んですよ
の本がありましてですね謎の独立国家ソマリランドと
早稲田の先輩が書いた本なんでございますが
こちらによると現在世界で一番危ない国ソマリアは3つに分かれます
どんな3つかというと一つはですね
もう争いが絶えない国じゅうずっと清掃している
南部ソマリアまるで北斗の拳状態ということでございます
南ですよ南は北斗の拳6
ん
その真ん中はどうなんだと真ん中はですよ皆さん何と海賊国家ターン
これ本当に現代の海賊がこんな可愛くないですね
海賊はくれたし
じゃあきたはどうなっているんですかというと
を知らないんですきたわー
噂では
誰かが国を治めてすごいいい国作っているらしい
まるでなペター
そまえなんと
このソマリランドに目をつけてですね
行ってみたん
ここでございますアフリカの地の
少年国家ソマリランドと
ここでですねドラゴン桜やろうと思って乗り込んでいきました
こんな国でございますセッション
ようこそそまりあんというと書いてありますが皆さん規制行かないでくださいね
外務省は即刻対してください入っております
ラクダのプレイですらくだ
このラクダをですねどんどん売って商売しているということでございました
ca はソマリランド志とこんなボロボロのお金を使っています
すげーインフレをしている国でございましてバナナを買うのにもですねなんとこんな金
いるんですよ
パナ分
サファリランド名物ラクダのランチ
こちらでございますねラクダ肉ランチこれいくらということでございまして
ラクダに付ランチを食べるとこんぐらい書かれちゃう
札束がー
すごい国なんでございますねー
海に出れば海賊はいるのかということでございますねさん
いたのか海賊は沈んでも者数9
最近とれ島られているんですよ海軍に
海賊最近絶滅状態ということですね
ソマレらの実際教育はどうなのかということでございます
僕いろんな国で教育の事情みたんですがソマリランドは一番低い所の一つでございます
こんな感じで黒板も破壊されているということでございました
ある学校の校長先生に出会いまして炙り好調というんでございますがこれ
マフィアじゃないですかね
好調なんですねこれでも一応
彼は言いました
ウチの国大学いなくてさーと
ってカレーと話してるうちんですねちょっとこの組で一発なら大学作ればいいなという
ことになりまして
ん
今だったら
彼をですよこの大熊弾けろとかね
生きるんじゃないかと思ってございます
女商人告発の大学でつくるいう現在プロジェクトをやっておりましたですねー
阿部て俺が日本でパートナーを探してくれよということでいろんなところでですね
プレゼンすればするほど避難が降りかかってくると日本は負けない
どこだよソレアドソマリランドリパーはあるのかぞ
いやーそんなことやってもインパクトないでしょリスク高すぎるし
君には戦略というのが出るか頭を使えとかですね
いろんなことを言われるんですけどもやっぱりそれでも染まりなのでやりたいぞ
いうことでございますこの目見てくださいよ
やりたいです安西先生
いうことでございまして今もなお頑張っている最中でございまして一人だけ恐竜車でな
1つば最悪米倉選手の先生からだけはですね
やろうじゃないかと言ってくれました
よし一人協力者を得たぞということでございましたですね
だんだん a 神懸かってくるですねやってみた日承認国家のみ承認大学にケース集と
いうことでございまして
目指せん大熊
こんな感じの仲間も徐々に増えていったと
先月副大統領
左にいるんですけどもみなさん何がすごいかれ未承認国家の副題てるんですよねぇー
マンガだそれは右手な感じるっ
右にいるのはですね未承認国家の大統領あと前でございますからね
ね
あやしいすぎるよ水早い感じでございます
ここでですね制限してまいりました俺たち大学に作るぞ
副大統領助けてくれという話をしたんですね
そしたら皆さんくださいこのテレビカメラがですねソマリランド12個の情報ニュース
を流しましてですね
いろんなとこからレスポンスがありました3時間後にですね
ロンドンにいるソマリランドの友達から厚み多用途
大学をしたいですねはたまたですね facebook に面白い書き込みがねきたり
するんですね
暗殺予告とかね
嫁ぶっ殺す数
振り子マジなんですねこれ僕のコメントなんですねー
ですまあ暑い最初ます日朝しないと
さしぶりに聞いたよ朝しないととかねえ
ねっ
ハアハアハアヒル日でも八重歯湧水ですよ
水でショート
こいつ写真なんです facebook なんでね
ダンサーさんの写真だと思います
こいつなんですよ僕の命を狙っている
いうことで現在命狙われてるなうみたいな感じで
こんなときにです皆さん例の大学院の開講式が迫っていた
どうしても行かなきゃいけない
いきまず命影れ
行かれますか
行かない
先生
行かなきゃダメ
散々悩みましてですね
結局ですね
ことにいたしました
護衛をつけました
後ろの返っいかにも頼りない勝ち
一応からしこれからしにこもってるけど
声を常に2人来ていた別ですね1日3000円で雇えるんですね
2人で6世
開校式やってみました
11月6日に中4日前でございます
japan ソマリアのオープンユニバースという名前でございます
左にいるの米倉先生でございます先ほど
なんとお客さんこんなと負けちゃう
このどこかに暗殺参加潜んた
壇上にはさっきの大統領アドバイザー服タイトルアドバイザーを聞けるん
何かあったらやばいぞ
がなんとかこのままつつがなく終わり大学院が無事オープンいたしまして
15人の生きてが来たと言う
なんと半に発見したぞ
ということで
この続きは
来週発売のこのまで[ __ ]ぞ
いうことでございは皆さん
ありがとうございます
僕も皆さんがこの作ったうん4を買ってくれたお金で声を雇い続けますのでどうか
よろしくお願いしたいと思うんですけども
最後に何が言いたかったかと申しますとですね
アジアのサーフィン5分でもプー智方でもいやいや3章に豪華でもと
な攻め前方すると不可能はないということをこれからもっとに活動していきたいと思い
ますのでみなさんぜひ一緒にやりましょうありがとうござました
ありがとうございまーす